I'm gonna talk more today about content
because you know increasingly it sort of
it has been driven home to me that the
language learning efficiency depends on
good content I noticed that I spend
almost as much time looking for content
as I do actually studying the language
that it's not quite true but I spent a
lot of time at it it's time consuming
and and sometimes you put a lot of
effort in the content it's not exactly
what you want so in the last video I
said there I discussed the content that
I have some of which you see behind me
that I said maybe we should have someone
at link who devotes his or her time
full-time on the whole issue of content
because we are redesigning the library
so it's gonna look a bit more like
Netflix and then we got it we want to
have really good stuff in there we want
to have you know content that either is
in our library for the people can access
and bring in that's going to be just you
know appropriate for them at that you
know level which works for them and and
on subjects that are of compelling
interest to them and actually that takes
a lot of work to put all that together
so I will put up a so are you interested
in working with us on that we're gonna I
think we're gonna go ahead and hire
someone we have put a job description up
on our website and I'm gonna leave a
link to that job description in the
description box here to this video and I
would invite anyone that wants to work
with the link team to apply for this
position you know you can look at that
what we're looking for obviously is
someone who is familiar with the
internet with technology who speaks
languages who is interested in who has a
high energy level we would prefer
someone located in their office in
Vancouver but we're gonna take the best
person we can find so whether they're
for that person works with us remotely
or works with us in our office in
Vancouver will depend entirely on what
kind of candidates we see and who we
think is going to be you know the best
fit for the job this whole content thing
now I
see this as a as a sort of a collective
effort even though we'll have a person
managing this a lot of the content
I think that's out there is content that
probably cannot share in our libraries
or we have to try to approach people to
see if they'll sell it across our you
know a system our platform you know I
put so much effort in the past into you
know basically hiring someone to
transcribe as C mail in Arabic and then
only being able to import it for my own
use and I've approached s email to ask
them if we can sell their product across
our website and they hum and haw and I'm
gonna see them again in Fukuoka but I'm
not hopeful and very often we approach
people who have very good content they
don't even answer our emails but even if
we make people aware of where this stuff
is people can import it into link or
they can simply access it for their own
use I think the idea that we would have
someone coordinating the whole issue of
where to find good language learning
content whether we can import that link
or whether we can direct our members to
go there and import it for their own use
you know it really doesn't matter until
to that extent if we get help from
people they are helping everybody else
whether these people are members or link
or not obviously for that but it is
something that we want to address and
link you know on the subject of content
so someone like Justin just since I
mentioned this here I've had so many
good suggestions come up in the comments
here to my videos a couple of very good
sites for Turkish one of which I can't
remember the name right now but I
downloaded a bunch of stuff and I have
approached them sent them an email
asking them if we can use this material
that link my experience is they won't
even answer my email but also the
suggestion about using learning
languages on Netflix so I started doing
that that's a very interesting extension
for Chrome and so I watched a Netflix
movie and I see the the Turkish in this
case because I'm learning Turkish
the Turkish subtitle and then below that
the English translation more or less
good translation and then I have the and
I can go sort of frame by frame with
arrow keys I can move to the next line
in the text and then I can look up
individual words the problem is that if
you're sort of reading both the Turkish
and the English translation and looking
upwards
you're really not watching the movie and
what I really would prefer to have is
sort of a transcript and even there if I
get a transcript there's so many parts
of the movie that are just you know the
sound of a car the sound of shoes the
sound of a door closing there's lots of
sort of action sections in the movie
what would be the best would be if
within each episode of a movie that I'm
watching like right now I'm watching a
movie called good news I'm not watching
the whole movie because it's very all
these Turkish soap operas are very soapy
dramatic and that districts on and on
but it's interesting and but if I had
extracts of dialogue with the an ideally
with audio then I would study those and
I would increase my vocabulary so that I
would get more and more of the movie as
I watch the movie ideal situation I
don't know if that's possible there are
again just googling around you can find
that there are ways that you can extract
the transcript so we are going to look
at and see if there are some ways that
we can facilitate people you know
importing sort of time-stamped you know
audio and text into link I don't know
what's achievable we've asked our
technical people to look at it but that
would be one example you know the way we
can import you know videos from YouTube
where there are subtitles and then these
become lessons but even to find good
stuff with subtitles is a lot of work so
again if we can sort of collectively and
with the sort of coordination by one
person here who would be working with
link to develop better content for us
but that would benefit everyone that
maybe we can make
whole content thing easier like I don't
want every time I want to okay I have my
mini stories but after all the mini
stories get tiring they're a bit rapid
you know repetitious so I'm looking for
new stuff and then then there's this
constant searching for appropriate and
interesting content if we can make this
more readily available and also direct
people to where this stuff is available
and take advantage of things like
Netflix and songs that are out there and
you know YouTube and stuff so that that
really because I've convinced that and I
don't mind paying for content oh I don't
mind paying for s email I don't my
paying for anything this is that's good
I mean we pay for a tutor if you pay $15
an hour for a tutor you can pay 15 or
$20 or $25 for excellent content and
content is the key driver if you have
and even though as we've discussed that
you know there is this problem that you
know the frequency falls off so
dramatically but one of the interesting
things I found in going through this
Turkish soap opera go new with this
learn learn languages with Netflix where
you get one sort of sentence at a time
that I know a lot of that vocabulary so
the vocabulary in the movie the sort of
simple casual dialoguing back and forth
is actually a lot easier than if I try
to bring in a newspaper article for
example in Turkish and there it's just
all unknown not all but so
overwhelmingly unknown words whereas I
had the impression at least that the
sentence by sentence dialogue that I was
following had a lot more words that I
already knew so I I would really like to
get at that as study material and I D I
think we can extract the transcript but
if we can also get the audio then I
could be really warming you know
improving my vocabulary so that I can
then sit and enjoy the movie at Netflix
anyway we're gonna get someone we're
gonna get someone to get on this whole
subject of optimizing content for
language learning in general and
specifically add link so if you're
interested you
working with the link team have a look
at that job description which is posted
on our website and please get in touch
with us thank you for now bye
you